[Musica]
Esatto faccio tante cose pensate quanto
è difficile fare un reddito intero
dunque quando i ragazzi del telefono Mi
hanno chiamata per fare la performance
Io ho detto alla ragazzi Assolutamente
no Se io vengo qui Voglio fare lo speech
perché devo far rosicare la gente sui
social professionali aggiungendo keynote
speaker Quindi ora Io ho il mio pollo
rosso ho il mio archetto o le slide
fatte da me e potrò iniziare mettendo le
mani così
respirando nel microfono
i commenti online ricchezza o monnezza
Seguitemi in questo viaggio che inizia
il 23 di marzo di quest'anno mentre sto
guardando la finale del talent show a
cui ho partecipato e sto guardando
questa finale a un televisore seduta su
una ghiacciata seria di plastica nera in
una stanza che è circondata da teli neri
sotto alle tribune del pubblico perché
anche io sono in finale e sto aspettando
di entrare in scena è il più grande
teatro di posa d'Europa me l'hanno detto
3 fonici diversi 15 credo
e da sopra dalle tribune arriva un boato
non ogni volta che qualcuno ride o
applaude o batte i piedi ed è un'onda è
un'onda continua che mi arriva poi in
differita anche dal televisore quindi è
un'onda di emozione di rumore a cui tu
non riesci a dare veramente un
significato dopo un po' inizia a suonare
il panico gli sparico gli sparico ci
portano in questa stanza blocchi di 3-4
e poi ci portano dietro le quinte a
blocchi di 3-4 ci dicono che è perché
essendo una diretta e ci sono un milione
duecentomila persone che fanno da
spettatori e vogliono avere uno
spettacolo più fluido possibile Secondo
me è perché ci avevano paura che
qualcuno gli pigliasse male e ha solo
bisogno di fare un cambio Comunque mi
portano dietro le quinte ho 5 minuti mi
fanno levare il cappotto la costumista
ha scelto proprio un tailleur giallo
quindi ho paura di sporcarlo sta in
piedi come un corazziere non tocco
niente mancano 4 minuti mi aggiustano il
trucco Oddio come farò stasera a
togliermi questa maschera utilizzandone
di trucco userò L'acqua ragia Non lo so
mancano due minuti mi danno il microfono
in mano penso che forse ho tempo per una
gomma da masticare No Oddio se poi mi
resta la gomma da masticare in bocca a
Dio che come faccio mancano 30 secondi
visione a tunnel vado sul palco
quando sei sul palco il tuo cervello è
diviso in due da una parte c'è l'attrice
che fa le sue cose nella sua performance
e dall'altra c'è il regista che
controlla se sta andando tutto bene
oppure no E quella sera lì di fronte a
questo Tsunami di facce io devo fare
andare subito bene le prime tre battute
perché in televisione sono cruciali non
è come in teatro che la gente oramai ha
deciso di passare un'ora in una stanza a
dividere il bagno con gli altri e quindi
oramai sta seduta lì in televisione la
gente cambia quindi le prime tre battute
devono entrare Io faccio la mia prima
battuta e si incaglia come una ringa in
un commento dei giudici faccio la
seconda battuta la terza battuta non mi
ricordo neanche se entra No ma il mio
regista interno mi ha detto ok portare a
casa la missione porta la casa ricordo
che la gente un po' al riso un po' no
intanto di defibrillavo con una battuta
che funzionava ma non sta andando bene
quindi finiscono la mia performance con
tutta la grazia di cui sono capace mi è
arrivato dietro le quinte con l'assoluta
convinzione di aver fatto la peggiore
performance della mia vita di fronte al
pubblico più ampio della mia vita io so
che il mio problema non è in quel
momento lì e non è alle 3 del mattino
mentre me ne torno a casa a mangiare i
fagottini che mi ha fatto mia madre il
mio problema sarà la mattina dopo i
commenti online perché io c'ero già
stata in TV quindi lo so cosa succede
quando ti senti così mi sento
particolarmente male perché la prima
puntata non era andata così sette giorni
prima Qui ci vorrebbe un bel suono di
arpa per il flashback
sto guardandomi se sei in televisione a
casa mia nel calore della mia famiglia
umore è completamente diverso quella
puntata l'avevo registrata mesi prima e
lì tutta un'altra storia avevo fatto
tutte le cose che fa il buono nel film
prima di farcela Quindi avevo dormito in
un albergo terribile Poi avevo ascoltato
Hitman di Eminem che fa i comici va un
casino Poi mi ero fatta la meditazione
guidata con LeBron James che mi spiegava
come sfangarla nella vita mentre
lavorava a maglia ci avevo l'occhio
della tigre e l'orecchio della quaglia
il gomito dell'opossum avevo tutto
e ho spaccato ho spaccato anche perché
abbiamo avuto l'augurio di un fonico
dietro le quinte prima di entrare che mi
ha detto ragazzi t'ho visto dietro le
quinte sei bravo come fa sto lavoro
quindi non poteva andare male siccome
era una puntata registrata addirittura
me l'ha detto guarda in fase di
montaggio abbiamo dovuto tagliare delle
risate perché erano troppe ah ah io
guardo mio marito negli occhi gli dico
Luca la nostra vita sta per cambiare
adesso dovrò prendere delle decisioni
tipo mi chiamerò Giorgio fumo official
Giorgio fumo therial non lo so dobbiamo
pensarci voi avete avuto lo spoiler non
è andata bene Sono arrivata terza
si è girata la classifica al contrario
sono No ero terzultima con un 4% di voti
che comunque è un piccolo partito
e il giorno dopo i commenti non erano
gentili Che cos'è successo i miei
commenti
Questo è come si è svolto il sentiment
nelle mie opinioni il giorno prima la
settimana prima no un genio cioè l'erede
della satira in Italia la settimana dopo
le battute del Cucciolone Cioè senza
scampo e il punto non è tanto il
commento negativo o la quantità è
l'enorme mole di commenti negativi e
l'oscillazione soprattutto che tu
subisci da genio No in un in uno
strettissimo montare di tempo e io avevo
capito che dovevo affrontare questa
situazione con calma dignità e classe
Se decidi di intraprendere una carriera
artistica questi momenti saranno
abbastanza plausibili Nel tuo percorso
Quindi bisogna dotarsi di un bel pigiama
per piangere
un piumone di quelli che fanno tanta
massa in cui ti puoi nascondere dentro
una famiglia che ti supporta e una
colonna sonora tipo io piango con i Pink
Floyd Perché piangere con Adele è
veramente Basic
e anche se qualcosa dentro di lei ti
dice no non dovrei dargli importanza
arriveranno i commenti e tu te li
leggerai tutti
solo che scoprirai una cosa anche mentre
ti stanno massacrando online tu dovrai
alzarti vestirti andare all'aeroporto e
prendere un aereo per fare uno
spettacolo in un'altra città perché
questo è il tuo lavoro adesso
devi andare e devi farlo bene e quindi
ti devi tirare su in una qualche maniera
terza puntata poi smesso con gli
aneddoti
qualche mese dopo quindi poco tempo fa
vado a fare uno spettacolo in un teatro
che viene registrato che finisce in una
puntata di un programma che va benissimo
e va talmente bene che il pubblico è
talmente Ampio che questo giro sia i
commenti positivi che i commenti
negativi Ma io non l'avrei mai preso in
maniera così equilibrata Se non avessi
fatto tutta una serie di ragionamenti
che adesso io condividerò con voi
intanto cominciamo dal primo consiglio
che mi hanno dato
Questo è il consiglio standard Che si
dice a qualcuno che inizia a leggere
opinioni su di sé ed è nella Top 3 dei
consigli più inutili della storia
dell'umanità al secondo posto dopo
calmati
e prima di me l'hai provata non pensarci
a nessuno è mai stato utile questo tipo
di consiglio ed è anche
antropologicamente sbagliato e ora Voi
direte Ah anche antropologa Sì questa è
la storia dietro questo tipo di
situazione Noi abbiamo inventato il
linguaggio per dirci l'un l'altro di non
mangiare quella bacca perché quella
Bacca è velenosa e quindi le persone gli
uomini danno hanno iniziato a valutare
molto positivamente le persone che gli
dicevano non mangiare quella bacca
perché quella Bacca è velenosa e quindi
è nata la prima brava persona della
storia come tutte le persone della
storia doveva soddisfare dei bisogni di
una piramide che ho riassunto e uno dice
sei un ominide devi prima soddisfare i
bisogni alla base Ma la prima brava
persona della storia si è resa conto che
se riusciva ad avere soddisfatti i
bisogni un pochino più in alto cioè
quelli sociali aveva automaticamente un
vantaggio nel soddisfare anche i bisogni
di base
Perché il gruppo di persone che non
andava a cacciare il bisonte avrebbe
dato anche lui un pezzetto di bisonte
mentre la persona ha troppo per
Sara nel gruppo non avrebbe mangiato
quindi nasce anche la prima cattiva
persona della storia e lo strascichismo
se non piace al gruppo finisce che muori
da sola nella foresta pessima esperienza
una stellina nessuno lo raccomanda agli
amici
questo terrore a noi è rimasto anche se
adesso probabilmente Siamo tutti troppo
intolleranti al lattosio per mangiare il
bisonte latte di bisonte Noi abbiamo
paura quando un gruppo di persone non è
felice di quello che stiamo facendo e ha
perfettamente senso che sia così solo
che prima magari eri antipatico a una
persona su 10 ma adesso sui social non
solo che come Messi espone ma tutti
veniamo esposiamo un enorme quantità di
persone che possono essere non felici
della nostra esistenza e ora facciamo un
test Vi piegheremo pregherei di
rispondere
con un urlo chi crede fate chi crede che
la risposta giusta sia la a
nessuno Ok chi crede che la risposta
giusta sia la b
è molto bello perché vuol dire che non
vivete sotto un sasso Sì la gente ti si
beve nei commenti quindi servirebbe un
metodo un po' meno emotivo per valutare
quello che ci sta succedendo quando ci
arriva qualcuno che c'è se beve con i
commenti ci servirebbe un metodo che ci
aiutasse ad avere una misura di che cosa
sta succedendo alla nostra reputazione
online
Io sono Giorgia fumo sono solo una
comica ma sono anche Sono un ingegnere
e 12 anni fa per la mia tesi di laurea
io ho realizzato un modello matematico
per l'analisi dei commenti e
dell'opinione online che permettesse di
valutare la reputazione di un Brand ho
praticamente creato una specie di
termometro matematico su quanto i marchi
loro prodotti fossero apprezzati oppure
no Poi ho creato un altro modello
matematico che si è alzato la base di
una delle prime piattaforme di
valutazione degli influencer e della
loro capacità di influenzare le persone
e faccio ancora questo lavoro part time
nella mia area di marketing intelligence
e faccio consulenze a grandi aziende
multinazionali Marchi eccetera e spero
che questa roba sia vera tutta questa
roba che ha inventato perché quest'anno
ho deciso di analizzare me stessa come
se fossi un brand
quando ti specchi nei commenti online
chiaramente ne devi avere una certa
quantità e istintivo dare più peso ai
commenti negativi perché i commenti
positivi ti fanno sempre un po' di Vabbè
mia mamma mi ha messo like e dopo un po'
inizia a darmi per scontati mentre i
commenti negativi ti sembra sempre che o
no questa persona mi ha scoperto in
realtà io sono una truffa
quindi dobbiamo prima fare un passo
indietro a fare uno studio su come
nascono le reazioni online se a qualcuno
piace qualcosa la prima reazione e
mettere un like perché ti costa poca
fatica e pensi di aver fatto il tuo
dovere chi ti scrive un commento
positivo quindi ha un grandissimo valore
perché si è preso lo sbatti di scrivere
viceversa Come nasce un commento
negativo un commento negativo
soprattutto perché non tutti i social
permettono di lasciare feedback negativi
facili e
quando hai la rabbia e devi scrivere
devi scrivere a quella persona che odi i
suoi capelli hai questo istinto che ti
dice di dire a questa persona che odi
quello che ha quello che ha fatto
tendenzialmente se hai una vita triste
le persone felici escono questo
Poi c'è l'altro tipo di reazione che è
la condivisione che è la più preziosa
per chi fa lavoro sul Digital perché
vuol dire Io amo così tanto quello che
hai fatto che mi fa sembrare figo se lo
condivido Quindi questo è Come nascono
le reazioni e Uno potrebbe chiedersi Ok
ma perché allora su internet C'è tanta
indignazione c'è tanta cattiveria se
tutti sappiamo che dai commenti negativi
un po' frustrazione perché per alcune
persone l'indignazione la rabbia è
l'unica maniera di partecipare a una
conversazione perché non ha
effettivamente niente da aggiungere è
come il biglietto in economy per questo
volo di linea che è la conversazione
solo capire un biglietto in Economy non
significa essere il pilota e non
significa essere l'ingegnere che ha
progettato le ali è solo un piccolo modo
di partecipare senza per forza
aggiungere qualcosa all'esperienza degli
altri
Quindi come faccio la mia analisi
Intanto devo scegliere le fonti escludo
i giornali nel mio caso specifico perché
sicuramente erano comunicati stampa e
non si schierano quindi decido di
analizzare i social ora i social hanno
diversi gradi di aggressività mediamente
e quindi sicuramente voi avete in mente
una classifica so che posso aspettarmi
dei commenti più aggressivi su un social
piuttosto che su un altro secondo
parametro il tempo non posso davvero
dire se una festa è venuta bene o no se
non ho ancora fatto finire la festa nel
mio caso specifico avevo bisogno di
aspettare un pochino di tempo prima di
farmi un'idea davvero e soprattutto
essere in lacrime con tre ore di sonno
avendo mangiato soltanto un panino
ghiacciato un tè bollente non è lo stato
emotivo giusto per trarre conclusioni
Terzo punto Esistono dei punti fissi da
considerare non tutti le crisi diventano
dei disastri totali tutti abbiamo una
negatività fisiologica è un problema
quando questa negatività fisiologica
della nostra reputazione a raggiungere
livelli particolarmente importanti ma
finché oscilla non è un problema
semplicemente c'è e poi bisogna decidere
a chi volgere la propria attenzione
vogliamo dare retta a questo tizio che
confonde i puntini puntini con la
virgola e ci dice che facciamo schifo o
è meglio dare attenzione a persone che
amano quello che stiamo facendo e che
magari un giorno compreranno un
biglietto per vederci dal vivo
è un cambio di prospettiva che Ci
obbliga a concentrarci sulle persone con
cui vogliamo veramente avere uno scambio
terzo Qualunque sia il vostro film Un
libro preferito se andate a cercare le
recensioni ci sarà qualcuno a cui ha
fatto cagare da sempre nella storia
quindi è vero non potete piacere a tutti
e adesso abbiamo dei dati che ce lo
dicono Quindi Che cos'è che ho trovato
questi sono dei dati assolutamente
affidabili e a cui Voi credete perché io
ho gli occhiali
Intanto i commenti positivi di tutto
quello che ho fatto online erano di gran
lunga superiore ai commenti negativi
perché ripetiamolo magari quello che
senti in un momento in cui sei deprivato
dal sonno e sei emotivamente molto
attaccato a quello che hai appena fatto
non è così vero Non è detto quella tua
sensazione su qualcosa sia così drastica
siamo spesso molto duri nel valutare noi
stessi due i commenti negativi sono di
due tipi ci sono i commenti negativi che
possano avere una qualche utilità anche
se tendenzialmente una persona che vi
vuole fare una critica costruttiva non
vi iscrive un commento online è
probabilmente un vostro amico qualcuno
di cui vi fidate vi dice Senti le posso
dire la verità quel pezzo fa schifo
cambialo però ecco è difficile che vi
arriva attraverso il canale di qualcuno
che scrive fai schifo Sei brutta
Però siccome mi sto trattando come un
Brand voglio essere professionale ho
approfondito anche i commenti negativi
che non significano niente e ho scoperto
degli insetti interessanti come per
esempio che il 100% delle persone che
critica il mio naso e la mia bocca ha
una foto profilo che include il mare
una grande quantità di quelli che dicono
che non faccio ridere le donne non fanno
ridere hanno il profilo di coppia
e una soverchiante percentuale di
persone sataniche uomini ma soprattutto
donne hanno come frase invio qualcosa
tipo La bellezza salverà il mondo nata
principessa questo tipo di cose qua
quindi ora potete indagare fra i vostri
amici e scoprire chi barra tutte queste
Caselle e magari sono persone che come
Hobby la sera vanno a scrivere
Ok quindi dopo aver fatto questa analisi
aver sentito la mia storia che cosa ne
traiamo
bello specchiarsi negli altri
giustissimo avere un feedback di quello
che sta succedendo Ma se quello che gli
altri dicono di voi che sia un applauso
o che sia una critica vi Deve bloccare
dal fare quello che sapete fare dal
ballare dal cantare dal dare con questo
vostro contributo artistico nel mondo
Allora forse è il momento di distaccarsi
un po' grazie